hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey i have a pretty fun topic
tonight it's going to be about the dubov
tarash
which sounds like a pretty specific
opening but tonight i want to show you
how it can help fill some holes that you
might have in your repertoire uh and how
it's an excellent backup option if
you're hoping to kind of surprise
someone
it's a great way to sort of take the
game into your own hands as the player
with the black pieces against one d4 you
have a lot of
a lot of sway in which direction the
game is going to go in if you know the
dubai tarash
so to start with i want to look at not
the duba of terrash and say you know
what happens against 1d4
so me personally i play openings like
the nimzo indian or the ragozan in
or some of those closed catalan lines or
open catalan lines where you start with
knight f6
against something like c4 you go e6
and you know against knight f3 or g3 you
go with d5 against knight c3 i don't
personally play the queen's gambit
declined but you could play the queen's
gambit declined here
or the nimzo indian
and this is a really nice way to start
the game with black against one d4
because it keeps your options open and
your openings are going to stay pretty
consistent if you have this set up right
you can do this against uh many many
things you can do this against the
london for example you can do this
against two knight f3
you can just go for this knight f6 e6 d5
setup kind of against anything
now almost anything is is what i should
say because i want to introduce you guys
to this move order here starting with
the english okay
so a lot of people are happy to play
something like e5 against the english
take the game into sort of different
territory or the even the symmetrical
for example uh but many players myself
included uh are still hopeful that we
can get into our setups against d4 that
we we so desire you know something like
knight f6 our opponent can transpose
immediately or if they want to do
something like g3
again we're gonna have our consistent
plan here playing knight f6 e6 and d5
keeps things a little bit simpler for
the player with the black pieces if
you're playing similar setups against d4
against c4
then you're going to be able to
understand your positions a lot better
but it turns out white can make our life
a little bit harder here with this move
knight to c3
and this move order specifically is why
i myself decided to pick up the duba of
terrace i was having a lot of trouble
figuring out what to do against this so
who has any idea what happens if we
tried to go for our e65 plan that we've
seen before what do you think white can
go for after e6 here
yeah e4 right away
and you can still go d5 and you should
still go d5 probably but this is going
to be a very very different line to ones
that we've seen before
where we're going for our plan of knight
f6 e65
after e5 black has to know quite a bit
in this opening variation there's a lot
to know white has a lot of options and
i'm not entirely certain black
completely equalizes at the end of it so
pretty scary stuff uh this e4 move after
two knight c3
uh but the good news for us is the
duboff trash is here to save the day we
can get into uh kind of similar
positions uh where we are going for this
e6 d5 plan
and so how are we going to get there it
seems like if we play e6 right away
we're just walking right into pawn to e4
well it turns out that the way to do it
is to play two c5 and what is the point
of this move well now if white's going
to try this move e4 we can very very
easily go knight to c6 and this is going
to be a much better setup for us than
when we played e6
first of all white is not getting this
e5 move second of all we have not
committed our e pawn to e6 and we can
develop uh very very comfortably here
uh and we can continue actually with e6
and d5 uh just to name one line we of
course can also go for these setups as
well and this is just not going to be
the best setup for white here you don't
really want to commit this pawn to e4 if
you're not getting e5
as we saw in that other line
so 2c5 essentially makes white go back
into into normal territory here
so we're going to see knight f3 by white
and now again we can go e6 because the
c5 move has delayed our opponent's plans
now g3 and again if e4 here i'm not sure
if people can really try this but we can
go knight c6 and again we're going to go
for something similar e5 would be a
mistake because knight g4 just picks up
this pawn
so e6 g3 and now knight c6 is what we
can start with you can also start with
d5 totally fine
uh we're gonna go d5 here
takes takes
uh and d4 for white is the key idea here
if white uh tries to waste time by
playing something like castles black is
going to be very happy to play d4
himself grabbing all this space making
this knight look a little bit awkward so
d4 for white is the way to play uh and
at the moment we are in a normal terrash
so what makes it the do-bob tarash does
anybody know doobav's special idea here
that sort of revived the tarash opening
in general
what does dubov want to play in this
position
okay first of all what moves look normal
what would be a normal idea here
yeah you just want to develop right so
bishop e7 is the move they played in the
olden days and this is sort of the the
mainline terrace if i'm remembering
correctly and unfortunately uh after
let's put castle's castles on the board
um unfortunately for black this can be
quite uncomfortable uh there are a
number of different moves in the
database this bishop can kind of go
anywhere white can immediately take on
c5 or white can try and make your life a
little bit harder by going b3
and going for really annoying ideas like
knight to a4 like just for example here
knight e4 bishop b2 and knight a4 and it
turns out it can be very very difficult
for black to actually hold on to all the
pawns here the c5 pawn is going to be a
pretty big weakness we're not really
thrilled about playing c takes d4 when
white's bishop is very very well placed
to already target this pawn on d5 and
white's other bishop is well placed to
support the square in front of the pawn
just a very good iqp setup for white in
this instance compared to the normal
iqp's that you should be getting
and yeah like i said i mean there are a
number of ways to go about this here
with white uh bishop to g5 sort of
forces you to do something with this
pawn immediately due to these combined
threats
and it's just not so comfortable for
black
uh and so people didn't play this so
often at the top level because white has
all these options you have to know so
much and you might not even be fully
equalizing with some serious structural
deficits
but dubov had a fantastic idea here not
to waste time by developing slowly but
just to force the issue in the center
right away play c takes d4
knight takes d4 and rather than develop
the bishop to the slower square of e7
we're coming out to f6
where is duboff putting this bishop do
you think
yeah bishop c5 and immediately it turns
into a very uh concrete variation we are
threatening the knight on d4 forcing
white's hand to play in the center
before he could comfortably finish
development before you know he could get
his ideal setup b3 bishop b2 before he
could
securely blockade this pawn uh already
we are fighting for the square in front
of of the d-pawn
now uh
what comes to mind here as a potential
tactical refutation of this opening what
might
uh what might white try here to say
you've you've gone too far you can't do
this just yet
you can protect the knight um something
like bishop e3 is is playable but i
think even queen to b6 might give you
some some serious problems here i can
renew this threat
and uh turns out after something like
knight to c6 we can actually delay
taking this knight take here instead and
you've got some very serious uh
very serious problems to to think about
here
so defending the knight
white's not lost but
that's not going to be one of the more
testing variations here
so whenever you open up the d file
early on it of course increases the
pressure against this pawn right so this
would be the first thing that comes to
my mind if i had never seen this opening
before like hey wait a second i'm
attacking this pawn a lot of times maybe
i can tactically
uh win it
manny says queen b6 knight a4 yeah
that's going to get into some
theoretical lines where i'm going to
check on this diagonal
um yeah queen b4 is is the move and then
this is actually still a playable line
though manny for for white it's a piece
sacrifice temporarily but white might
get it back the end of the day though
black is doing well in that variation
so this is a just a two-move tactic here
white can make a threat and also attack
the d-pawn and then white it's going to
be able to capture the d-pawn on the
next turn there's not really a way for
for black to stop it
very very concrete we just make two
threats at the same time
yeah manny has the right idea in the
chat we just go knight to b3 and look at
that we've made two threats at the same
time bishop's attacks so is the pawn you
cannot defend both and this is one of
the main variations
in the opening
knight p3 is one of the two main main
moves here the other one being knight
takes c6 we're going to take a look at
both
so to start with black has to save the
bishop and it does turn out that the
reason why maybe they didn't play this
bishop c5 move uh in the olden days is
this is just just upon sacrifice you
have to be ready to give up this pawn
amongst other things so to start with
before we get into the main line theory
and what people tend to do at the top
level i thought it was worth spending a
little bit of time up at the front about
what happens if white actually takes
this pawn because if you're not
comfortable when white takes the pawn i
think especially at you know slightly
lower levels maybe like a thousand to
two thousand people are gonna see this
two move tactic if you play this in a
serious game against them and you have
to be ready to respond against it i find
players
at all levels are very materialistic and
so if they haven't seen it before they
might be very very tempted to snatch
this pawn they might think you've messed
up early
so let's take a look what are we going
to do after knight takes d5 how
is black doing okay here
well it turns out there's not an
immediate you know tactical refutation
or anything white is allowed to capture
this pawn
uh and we're just gonna play the simple
move bishop to e6 um we're just going to
develop our pieces keep the pressure up
against whites
and uh
and try and uh get active play for the
pawn
so once again i think a few moves should
immediately spring to mind here for
white right white has just spent some
time capturing the pawn we've attacked
the knight so
i think in general a very human thing to
do is to try and play as quickly as
possible here with white you know you
snatched your pawn now you want to get
out of dodge uh solve your problems get
castled and then claim that you're up a
pawn in the long run
so with those ideas in mind what what do
you think about with the white pieces
here
yeah taking either piece right you know
why waste time moving the knight again
when you can just trade the pieces so
again i think these are the most human
moves but it turns out they are
definitely not the best in this position
black is gonna have a very easy gain if
white takes either of these pieces so
we're gonna look at those two lines
first but then i also want to mention uh
while we're just in this position the
move e4 is a very serious try uh and i
think the move knight c3 is the move uh
at least that irwin lemie uh recommends
as the best try for white in this line
in his chestable course which by the way
if you are interested in picking up this
opening it's a great chestable course
it's not too long and it's very
informative on the different lines so
give that a look i definitely use that
as a good reference when uh when
prepping for this lecture
so let's start with taking the bishop
because i think this is the most natural
you know you see this bishop here
targeting this f2 pawn you start to
think maybe this guy is uh is the
problem piece for me
so knight takes b6
you might think that our idea is to keep
the queens on take back with queen b6
but it turns out we're actually quite
happy to take here on d1
and go in for this kind of end game i
say end game more of a queenless middle
game now why are we so happy about this
looks like our pawns are absolutely
awful horrible horrible pawns well
it turns out as always
this pressure down the a file is going
to be very very important in this
position
uh on top of that we immediately just
have a very concrete threat right like
this is a threat and white is gonna have
to do something about it otherwise he's
in in big big trouble
uh so it turns out there's a couple main
moves here knight to d2 is very very
sensible and i think that is
uh you know i keep saying the more human
idea when i say human idea you know
players at a certain level are going to
know this position but uh i'm talking to
you guys sub 2000 players i think your
opponent's probably going to try knight
to d2 uh i think that at some point
white is obliged to give up this bishop
for this knight and actually fix black
structure and we'll talk about why here
so
let's say knight to d2
let's see if we can come up with some
good ideas for black here how are we
going to continue
to press
not necessarily you know the move you're
playing right away but
in general what ideas are we keeping in
being necessary mind with the queens off
the board so i played k7 and uh
king e7 and rook hd 8. so
uh if we do move the king i am going to
disagree with you i think we should
castle here
um not necessarily because we're afraid
for a king's safety although maybe that
will be relevant but we actually do want
to have this open e file to our
advantage it's going to be very useful
for us to plant a brook here and target
this weakness in white structure which
is harder to do with the king on e7 um
so castle short is actually the main
move but the chat recommended the the
move i hoped they would which is
blundering away the game by taking the
pawn so the the duboff terrace
not known for for being the most
materialistic opening black is very very
often happy to play these positions down
a pawn with just very very uh solid
long-term compensation uh making white's
life very very tricky so what happens
here well of course white's gonna trade
and then just like bobby fischer your
bishop has has no way home and
wait we'll take his time king c2 king b2
and this bishop will will not survive
long in fact probably white should
include this so there's no knight before
stuff and then this this idea is just
very very concrete
very concrete and black is busted
so don't take that guy that won't turn
out well for you
um but okay let's put castles on the
board and let's say white captures
because if white does not capture
say something like a3 trying to defend
the pawn
uh it's actually black to move and and
pretty much win here there's like
there's not much that can be done
already for white
and then there was a question about
bishop takes a2 i'll take a look at that
as well in just a moment
well the work's not doing anything on
the a file anymore so
ada
i mean rook a to d8 is a very thematic
move oftentimes the rook will move here
in this opening but we actually just we
have a tactical knockout here that's i
think even even stronger than regate 2d8
we just have a knockout punch right away
and then we are also threatening uh
knight
d4 yeah this is a very common theme that
you may have seen before when white or
or black uh loses castling rights early
with both knights on the board you'll
find that attacking both of these two
squares at the same time gets pretty
awkward for for white to deal with so i
do think knight to d4 is just winning i
think knight to g4 is also winning
let me just blender check myself so okay
now knight to f knight to g4 is not good
enough knight d4
uh is the idea so let's let's try and
understand why
of course it's because white now has
time to take take the knight um and
these lines don't quite work because the
bishop comes back um so knight to d4
first but you are correct in thinking
that this is the idea say you try
something like e3
we can check
and
you are actually quite close to getting
just uh checkmated down these two files
right let's say
you go here i just check
and check
and take it take it slow take it easy
you know let's say you saved the bishop
knight d3 and
your bishop is not going to survive for
for much longer all these ideas
checkmate bishop's hanging it's just
over
um
okay so just a word of warning there how
easily things can go wrong for white
let's say you know they they start to
like their bishop on the long open
diagonal knight d4 already just strictly
winning in this position
so with that word of warning aside of
course white should capture this knights
which does fix your structure and then i
just want to take a quick look at what
happens if white plays a3 just holding
on to everything
like i said the open e file is actually
going to be very very relevant for us
and so just a move like rick ft8 and
like i said we're not getting the pawn
back uh super immediately but we're just
happy to play chess here
so i did put in just some uh some moves
as an example here it's actually very
difficult for white to reorganize the
pieces uh for example a move like knight
to f3 i think is already quite close to
to just being lost i think we can just
go like knight to d5
and you know bring in our bring in our
knight once again and again it's it's
going to be tough for white yeah black
is already significantly better here
like bishop g3 for example knight g4
if you take rook b8 rook takes
and all the rooks start to swarm the
bishop also coming in and again very
very easy for white to make a simple
mistake develop in the wrong way and
just be dead lost
um but it turns out knight to f1 i think
is the best reorganization for white
here
and then we're happy just to make some
threats i just gave bishop c4 as an
example there are numerous moves here
you really are just playing chess down a
pawn with a lot of active play knight e3
for example king e1 knight d5 something
like b3 c5
and already very active play uh
sacrifices are in the air
um
and
black is is definitely enjoying the
better side of things here white may
have this extra pawn
but there's just so many traps so many
tricks for white to look out for that i
do think it's very very difficult to
play practically which is probably why
we don't see this lens so often
um just to continue the example line a
little bit something like this is how
you would reach a more or less equal end
game where yes white is up a pawn in the
long run but it's very clear to me that
white is not going to be able to make
use of this extra e pawn anytime soon
and i would much rather be black with my
rooks connected pressure on the files
and just enjoying a pleasant game
um okay so what was all that about that
was about what happens when
uh black or white plays knight takes b6
here remember we were saying we take on
d1
take away white's castling rights take
on b6 and then the mixture of these
kinds of threats with threats of knight
g4 knight d4 threats down the e file
give white or give black a very very
comfortable game and give white a lot of
problems very easy to just be strictly
lost here
and in my opinion i think that's uh if i
were a player with the white pieces who
had never seen the duboff terrace i
honestly think that this is going to be
the most common line that you run into
right somebody attacks your bishop takes
the pawn gets scared about the dark
squared bishop and next thing you know
you're in this position where there are
a thousand ways white can go wrong and
only one or two that where he can
survive the opening
okay so let's continue on then remember
i said there are a few other moves to
look at here what happens if knight
takes f6 this one is also going to be
very simple we che we take back with the
queen in this case castle's castles
something like bishop to d2
trying to develop here we are going to
immediately get our pawn back and this
is why black is doing fine in this
position again we're very active and
again white has problems developing
because you have to stay tethered to
this to this pawn
um the only game in the database here
white went queen d2 to try and develop
out with queen c3 and black simply
allows it it's totally fine we go bishop
c4 and again all this kind all these uh
all these bishops in the position are
are going to give black a a very
comfortable game you just immediately
get your pawn back and there is no
reason at all why black should be worse
so moral of the story the most
natural lines in my opinion knight takes
d5 and knight f6 and knight b6 no
problem at all for black very very easy
to get an active game
with that in mind let's take a look at
e4 here
uh e4 black does have to be a little bit
more careful uh it's very strong to
immediately challenge this queen
um on d1 make it pick a square
and there is some stuff to know here but
i just wanted to show an example line
something like queen to c2 stepping out
of the way we're gonna go rook to c8
introduce threats on the c file
something like castles and immediately
knight b4 we are able to capture on d5
castle ourselves we've dealt with the
annoying knight
sitting there on the d5 square and once
again
white has serious problems getting
developed we have a lot of active play
uh this bishop on b6 especially going to
be a very active piece and this pawn on
d5 doesn't really concern us that much
it's it's not exactly mobile and once
again black is going to be doing fine
expect to see black try and come come in
on the e file as normal stuff like queen
d7 and bishop h3 also very very
reasonable uh very common attacking
themes here that you've all probably
seen before
um
just to give an example line this is all
i put in before the lecture but let's
say
something like to e1 queen to d7 again
is a very normal idea
white needs to activate this dark
squared bishops let's say
queen f4 and again bishop h3 super
common attacking ideas that uh like i
said you've probably seen before we can
take
and something like rook c6 and we have
no problem at all uh kind of picking
this pawn back up playing a slightly
better position
okay so that's just one example after e4
again if you want all the details
i can't provide them to you in an hour
but one resource like i mentioned is uh
chessable chessball is a great course by
urban lemie that i highly recommend
okay last thing to check is knight c3
which again is potentially the most
testing uh the thing to know here is we
are no longer happy taking on d1 of
course because white is now taking back
with the knight we don't get all this
counter play because of white's king in
the center so we should keep our queen
on the board something like castle's
castles bishop g5 and again we're going
to play very simply we bring our rooks
to the open files we force the issue
with this bishop and
before too long stuff like knight b4
happens rook
f to e8 and uh
i ended the line here but just for
example knight e4 not going to give you
problems you just go queen e5
and again look at how awkward it is for
for white to try to develop queen in the
way of the rooks the rooks can't come to
the files pressure on this b2 pawn is
going to be relevant pressure on the e3
pawn also going to be very relevant this
knight threatening to jump into d3
and sacrificial ideas once again are in
the air
and with that i don't want to spend any
more time on knight takes d5 because at
least at the top levels people don't
really play this move and the reason
they don't play this move is the reasons
i just showed black has a lot of fun
white does not have a lot of fun but i
wanted to spend a lot of time at the
front here because i really do think in
a practical game uh below you know a
certain level below 2000 i don't think
many people are are going to be able to
resist the urge to capture this pawn for
free
so
any questions on knight takes d5 before
we move on to a couple model games in
the more normal lines that was a lot to
cover but hopefully the ideas are are
sort of sticking with you you know you
play actively with the pieces pressure
against the king in the center pressure
against white's queen side pressure
against the e pawn coming down the e
file if you keep those ideas in mind
you're going to be doing fine
all right any questions
all right we'll move along then
so
let's take a look at what happens
if white captures on c6 in this position
this i believe is one of the main lines
and it's also a one where white is going
to be in some trouble if he doesn't know
quite a bit
so for this game we're going to turn to
our hero daniel dubov against uh maxim
rajstein uh in one of our model games in
this variation so
uh dubov of course the namesake of the
opening uh is the guy who's been playing
it the most actually i don't know if we
can show the database ben
but if you look here in this position
the top game carl sundubov second game
mabayar of dubov nakamura dubov nakamura
dubov
dudadubov
this duboff guy he plays this opening
there's a reason it's named after him
um but okay d4 in this position
knight c6
bishop g2
uh c takes d4 knight takes d4 we've
reached the starting uh tabia for our
opening here once again bishop c5 is do
bob's idea
and today we are now looking at this
move knight takes c6 so at first glance
this might not make as much sense to you
right uh why take on c6 why allow black
to support his central pawn that was
once weak and isolated
when we could just play move like knight
b3
and as we saw maybe not even take right
away but at least leave this pawn
isolated and a little bit weaker so
what's the logic here why take on c6 and
allow b take c6 does anybody have an
idea
the hanging pawns okay so what do we
know about the hanging pawns structure
because it's not necessarily a bad thing
by itself
so they are a little bit weak because
they're on these half open files they
can be targeted
but of course the upside is that they
can give you extra space right i control
all these squares on white's half of the
board and white doesn't control those
squares on black's half of the board
but there is a very particular instance
where the hanging pawns are very very
bad and that is if you do not get them
to be sort of level with each other so
let me just throw some moves on the
board
let's say
um
okay let's say white passes for example
we get here
and white continues passing and we get
c5 for example so with this we have our
pawns together in the in the center they
control all these nice squares they're
also very very fluid like if we get rick
c8 for example
you can imagine black at any moment can
push d4 if he wants and continue
expanding this way also at any moment c4
could be played by black the pawns are
fluid they
don't defend each other yet but if they
need to we can step forward take even
more space and continue rolling with the
pawns so
when black is able to do this with the
hanging pawns they aren't necessarily a
weakness
however if we look at the total other
side of things let's say for example
something like knight a4 happens we come
back with the bishop this way something
like a3
b4
let's say develop you develop i develop
you develop
this is the absolute nightmare scenario
for black now it seems like we played
pretty normal moves whereas in the other
line i had to pass with white for a
while
um but black is i think just
positionally lost in in this position
it's it's that bad and the reason is
white was able to get control over the
backward pawn in black's camp so this is
the risk you're running when you have
these pawns on c6 and d5 if white is
able to achieve a setup like this it's
it's big trouble for black you're not
going to survive this game like just to
show an example line
say i put this knight on c5 something
like takes takes like already this
bishop is a demon and white has the
easiest play in the world we put the
rooks on the files we control all the
squares and black has none of that
active counter play there's no way these
pawns are going anywhere and black again
i think is just positionally very very
uh
you know busted here it's it's just too
tough
um so
our task when white takes on c6 is to
make sure that happens under no
circumstances whatsoever
so to start with uh let's look at this
move queens to c2 there are a variety of
moves here including castles first is is
an option uh knight a4 first also an
option but our response is going to be
pretty uh consistent against all these
moves so uh just throw castle's castles
on the board
here basically in some order white is
going for this idea so we're gonna look
at queen c2 first
now in the game do bob simply castles
which is fine
um castles and then we get bishop to b6
and this is basically our response
against white's entire entire setup even
if he starts with knight a4 we just go
bishop e6 and then you know you can get
to the exact same position
um here for example
uh but we're looking at this mover queen
c2 castles castles bishop b6 we put the
bishop on a square where it's defended
we keep it on this nice open diagonal
pressuring the way king's side and after
knight to a4 of course we're not going
to back down and give white full control
over the c5 square but we're gonna leave
this bishop here fighting for that
square
now in the game do bob chooses bishop to
d7 and i actually like this move quite a
bit now if you follow my recommendations
and go to this chessable course i've
been telling you about you're going to
learn about the bishop a6 move
but i think bishop d7 is actually uh
quite scary for for white to handle so
we're gonna stick with this move here
today
uh now
if black were to try to do or sorry if
white were to try to do something like
b4 right away we're not going to be
really as concerned this bishop here is
going to help us fight for the c5 square
a lot more and white is not going to
have any kind of easy way to just take
advantage of it in fact
i'm thinking of some tactics here but
maybe we should just keep it simple
queen e7 again fighting for this square
and if white wants to make any progress
eventually knight takes b6 is is gonna
have to happen there's just no way that
you can get away with knight to c5 here
for example i think a5 right away
is just concretely regaining control
over this square you cannot play a3
because i can take and there's no way
for white to to keep this the c5 square
under control
um so
uh b3 was played in the game first and
now once again our counter play is going
to come on this open file but we'll see
here after bishop to b2
uh that black is going to have some very
active ideas and
once again before we we show those i
just want to say knight takes b6 we are
always of course responding with a takes
b6 we love the open a file and we need
to control the c5 square
uh and white can kind of throw this in
at any moment it's just an idea sort of
inherent in the position
or white can delay it for as long as he
likes here for example in this case he
hasn't yet taken
um
and this line is very testing for a
reason because it looks like white is
sort of finishing development we've got
a bishop on a nice diagonal this knight
looks a little bit silly but it's going
to trade itself off here for this bishop
on b6
and it looks like uh black's counterplay
might be starting to slow down a little
bit like maybe maybe we are going to
pressure down the e file and that's
going to give us some play but it
doesn't look like a lot for black
so
black has to get a little bit creative
here
and come up with some fun ideas
so i'm curious if anybody can come up
with the move played in the game if
you're a fan
of alpha zero and this new age of chess
that it has brought upon then uh then
you might find this idea a little bit
faster
wow
yeah okay so knight g4 is pretty
concretely uh trying to use this bishop
on b6 to target f2
but remember white is not or white is
not really unhappy about making this
trade this is probably going to happen
eventually so it doesn't necessarily
make sense to force white's hand into
taking on b6 here and once this bishop
disappears i start to think that this
knight doesn't make as much sense
on the g4 square just yet at least just
yet
so not knight g4 in the game but the
chatroom has it uh we are in fact
launching our h-pawn down the board here
somewhat unexpectedly
uh but yeah h5 is is simply the idea
and the reason why we need to turn to
ideas like h5 is because in the long run
white is still going to be well set up
against the c6 d5 structure you know
these open files are right here ready
for the rooks to jump to
and much like in the classical terrace
that that i briefly showed at the start
white is going to be able to play
against this structure really really
well really easily you know
we saw all the problems black had
in the main line of the trash and those
problems exist here for black as well
just because we played bishop c5 didn't
mean that the structural deficits went
away
uh but because we played bishop c5
because we're so active we can launch a
kingside initiative at the same time
now if you do want to try the move h4 to
just slow us down
there are a number thing number of
things that black can go for here but
the main issue is that
something like actually i think knight
e4 would be a better move here
and the main issue is that this is a
little bit weakening of these this king
side structure you know once we go uh
with knight e4 even after this trade
sort of happens
and okay let's say something like b4
you'd be very very cautious about
leaving this f2 pawn uh undefended for
example let's say something like queen
to e7 hitting this guy a3
um
and okay i'm i'm not even uh playing
very very challenging moves and black is
able to get c5 with all this play so
let's say something like rook to d1
instead
now something like queen to e7 and it's
not hard to imagine that something like
knight f2 queen e3 is going to be very
upsetting for for white to have to deal
with maybe not immediately but these
long-term weaknesses are always going to
be there
um also worth mentioning we are never
unhappy about this trade with our light
squared bishop on the board this is sort
of uh suicidal for for white
so that's why h4 not such a good move
knight e4 gonna very concretely target
the weak spots in white's camp then
so in the game white tries this move e3
sort of challenging the dark squares a
little bit more really kind of ignoring
us on the king's side going for that
classical plan of controlling the square
in front of the c pawn
now of course if you say a you have to
say b we're gonna go with h4
um and now white decides it's time to
snap off this bishop mainly because we
were threatening some nasty things like
sacrifices on e3 especially in
conjunction with knight g4 or knight e4
so we get take take and now queen to c3
on the board
um and thus far duboff has played the
opening essentially perfectly
but here he does
start to go a little bit astray
so in the game
he kind of lost his nerve i think and
played something uh really played rook
c8 which is a totally fine move but it's
not really in line with our previous
play
it turns out that black can and and
should believe in the kingside
initiative here even further
uh and so moves like h3 moves like queen
c8 preparing bishop h3 both give black a
nice little edge so
just to show an example say h3 bishop h1
queen to c8 say you play a natural move
like rook f to d1 we're already gonna
come with bishop g4 we're going queen f5
next bishop f3 knight g4
and uh
white is sort of all but but checkmated
here just as long as we don't hang g7
ourselves but i think we can we can
handle that
um
very good position for black which if i
flip on the engine i think we're close
to minus one here yeah minus 0.7 already
and it's just it's a sad sad story white
already has to go f3
relying on some tactics
but we don't have to fall for those and
we're just going to bring in the rooks
target these weaknesses and and black is
doing very very well in this position
um
okay
so h3 not found in the game instead we
got rook to c8 and then the game sort of
took a wild turn we got rook to d1 takes
takes
i have no earthly clue why white thought
f takes g was a good idea i assume he
was relying on some sacrifices down the
f file but of course he should keep the
structure a little bit more compact with
h takes g
and then do bob does slowly but surely
take control over this game again
pressure down the e file is the main
idea of ours we see takes takes takes
takes
and here f6 stunts the attack and now
dewbov takes over by invading down the e
file
before the queen comes in white's king
is going to be weaker than blacks here
and at the end of the day
dubov organizes the pieces pins this
bishop on f2
and after king h7 raj jean actually goes
ahead and resigns here
difficult to stop bishop d5 and queen g2
also difficult to defend your bishop uh
and together
these things mean white is just dead
lost here so
what should white have done well instead
of
stuff like e takes d5 turns out white is
doing okay if we start initiating some
sacrifices here rick d to f1 first
something like takes takes takes and
white is going to get a lot of counter
play here
with sort of the weirdest structure i've
ever seen for black and the the exchange
sort of means nothing here um white is
gonna be able to take it back at any
moment
and we're gonna get some sort of drawn
end game uh looking like this
so uh great game by dubov
again all that all that was missing is
the the conclusion something like h3 and
then invading on these light squares
would have been deadly for for raj gene
to deal with
uh so let's do a quick recap of how we
got here
uh once again we're looking at this line
knight takes c6 b takes c6 now again the
danger for black is if white is able to
get this bind on the queen's side then
black is going to be positionally lost
so that's why moves like queen c2 knight
a4 are white's main idea
we see bishop b6 is our response to any
of these ideas bishop b6 and castles and
then uh defending our pawn on c6 is
important something like b3 and now we
get on get on the e file and once again
h5 h4 is our main source of counter play
now we're looking at the weak light
squares in the white camp we're looking
at potentially taking on g3
loosening up the dark squares we're
looking at invasions with queen c8
bishop h3 and very classical attacking
ideas that are all going to be working
out for black in this case
so one more time
this was knight takes c6 and then once
again white is doing this
we're doing castles bishop e6 rookie
eight and then we are launching our
attack on the king's side with h5 and
these ideas do remain pretty consistent
of course there's always theory to know
but these ideas do hold true
so questions on the knight take c6 line
questions here
okay
well in that case let's move on to the
main main line of the opening which is
going to involve knight to b3 and so for
that once again we are turning to our
hero daniel dubov
against hikaru nakamura this time i
believe this is the 2019 grand prix
so pretty serious event uh one of the
candidates qualifier events and how did
we get here well it turns out nakamura
does this exact annoying move order that
i was talking about and duba of course
responds with c5 we get uh i think
exactly the same move order as last time
d4 knight c6 challenging the d pawn
bishop g2 c takes d knight takes d
bishop c5 and now once again this knight
b3 move
we go bishop back to b6 and now rather
than knight takes d5 which we started
the lecture with of course cecaro plays
the much better move king side castles
uh so why is castle so good well
remember all those lines where we were
relying on things like queen takes d1
relying on pressure against the queen
with the white king in the center well
after castles those of course sort of
evaporate now white is always ready to
recapture on d1 with a rook and those
ideas just sort of don't exist anymore
all it takes is castling
so we now have a very serious problem
our pawn on d5 is attacked three times
and defended twice so what should we do
about it what can we do
so bishop e6 would be uh a normal way of
sort of handling things but uh as normal
in in the dubai terrace we want to be a
little bit more active we're not really
happy uh putting our bishop on this
square
i couldn't tell you the immediate
refutation or anything
maybe something like e3 is is going to
be an issue for us taking
again taking control of the square in
front of the pawn starting to set up
blockades something like knight b5 as
well would make a lot of sense
and if white can sort of simplify the
position get a good blockade again he's
just going to be positionally better
so
more active than bishop e6 what do we
think
yes so d4 is going to be our big idea
here uh once again it's important that
we play very very quickly very actively
and work to disrupt the the white pieces
so d4
moves our pawn from square where it's
attacked three times to a square where
it's only attacked twice no big deal
and of course it is attacking this
knight
there's no immediate tactical uh way to
win the pawn unlike with the pawn on d5
so white is obliged to respond in this
case with knight to a4 once again white
targets this bishop on b6 because this
piece really is sort of a monster here
targeting all these dark squares
uh now it's time to castle for us
and bishop g5 is going to be the move
that that gives us the most problems
here
um
and i believe this is the way to try and
win the pawn as well
although we can talk about that
variation as well so let's very very
quickly look at knight takes b6 maybe
this is the most concrete way to just
win the pawn now
knight or queen takes d4 rather than
knight takes d4
and here
black again is going to be getting very
very active play just in an end game
once again
pressure down the a file pressure down
these central files and it's that type
of dynamic equality that we saw in the
previous end game lines
uh but that isn't really in the spirit
of this variation i feel i feel like
that would be more in the spirit of the
knight takes d5 variation so instead
we're looking at the main move here of
bishop g5 this keeps the pressure up
doesn't simplify black's task keeps all
the pieces on the board and
makes black continue to deal with this
d4 pawn
in this case as normal we're looking for
pressure down the e file
now white does decide it's time to snap
off this bishop and hikaru's big idea
here is this move e3
so what do you think hikaru has in mind
against d takes e3 why go for this e3
move
it seems like it's going to allow black
uh to get rid of this d4 pawn which was
potentially the biggest weakness in the
position
looks like we get a lot of pressure down
the f file
okay so you're saying takes back with
the f pawn
okay
so why isn't white unhappy about d takes
e3
uh well
after that
he takes on d8
yep you do have that so queen d8 not so
not the answer
oh you can take back with the bishop and
then you're attacking b6 yeah it's it's
just that simple we're just gonna play
bishop takes e3 and when white has the
bishop pair he very much prefers the
opening of diagonals like like this one
like um
a7 to g1 here right in this position
this diagonal very closed this bishop a
little bit short on squares in this
position very comfortable square for
this bishop already raking down the
board and it's clear that black is going
to be at least practically a little bit
worse maybe objectively black is still
doing okay here but i wouldn't want to
be staring down these bishops uh over
the board for sure
so that's why d takes e3 doesn't really
concern hikaru he's got the bishop pair
he wants to open up the diagonals he
doesn't really mind allowing black to
get rid of this d4 pawn which is
potentially weak
uh dubov came for a fight and so he says
that's fine just like when my pawn was
attacked on d5 i'll push it down the
board a little bit more and so the pawn
now lands on d3 and that's what makes
this position sort of really really
double-edged black is playing this game
where the d-pawn continues running up
the board if white is going to be able
to corral this pawn then black of course
will just be down a pawn and white will
again have the bishop pair however if
this pawn is able to live and cause some
serious problems for white then of
course black is going to be very happy
in that case so
that's the nature of this sort of
variation you have this d-pawn it's both
your biggest weakness and your greatest
asset here uh harassing the white pieces
while also you know living a little bit
on the edge
so black or white in this case because
we did not open up this diagonal is
going to be happy to give up this bishop
otherwise something like h6 for example
and i mean this bishop might be getting
trapped if you don't trade it off
so we see takes and the very very
surprising move here g takes f6
um and once again it's all about the
d-pawn queen takes gives up the d-pawn
we're not going to do that we take with
the g pawn
um and this might literally be the worst
pawn structure that people intentionally
go for in the game of chess like this
this is pretty bad for a structure
but once again it's not about your
structural deficits the trash is already
sort of structurally bad for black um
it's about the act of play that black is
going to be getting so we take with the
g pawn and there's not really a way for
white to take advantage of all these
weaknesses at least not yet
um so now it's time for a3 once again
preventing stuff like knight b4 also
just securing the a pawn from this
pressure we're gonna go bishop e6 just
developing the bishop and by the way if
you're concerned about memorizing
opening theory you can play sort of a
few different moves here bishop e6
bishop f5 there's a lot of ways you can
organize the pieces here once again
we're just playing for dynamic play
piece play active ideas so bishop e6 was
do bob's idea
we get rick to c1
rook to c8 just uh avoiding the threat
uh rook d rick to c3 and then the key
idea for us here is that we do have
access to this nice e5 square for the
knight now our pawn structure may look
bad but it does help us control a lot of
these central squares
so knight to e5 in the game
knight to d4
is sakura nakamura's choice and then
here uh do bob does do something with
with this bishop but first captures on
c3 so it takes takes and now white
structure
has also seen better days so our pawns
may be weak but so are whites and
because of that because of our active
pieces black again is doing totally fine
uh dupov in this case decides it's worth
it to uh keep the bishop okay first he
attacks c3 we defend c3 and then dubov
retreats with the bishop
we get rook to e1 rook to c8 and it's
very clear you know dubois ideas come
very very naturally the the c file is
half open there's the weak c pawn to
above attacks the weak c
now a move that you might have been
thinking about does finally come on the
board white needs to get rid of this d3
pawn before something bad happens um
okay first work to c1 sorry queen to c5
and now the idea i was trying to talk
about f4 the only way to get rid of this
guy is to get rid of this knight only
way to get rid of this knight is to kick
it away with f4
dubob just jumps into c4 and we're going
to get the a3 pawn in return
takes takes rook to b1 knight back to d6
creating some threats
here knight to e2 and then the game
comes to a peaceful end after bishop f5
e4 uh hikaru offers a draw dubov accepts
but just to show you in the final
position uh almost the final position it
is actually black who stands a little
bit better which might be very very
surprising to you looking at the
structure
uh but it turns out
black's king not really going to be that
weak here when you compare it to white's
king it turns out you know moving your f
pawn is really bad and while having two
f-pawns is bad maybe it's not as bad as
moving your own f-pawn because the
second rank is going to be weak this
diagonal is going to be weak and
it is black who has the more active play
here so do bob's move bishop f5 does
equalize the position but i do think
black is a little bit better after this
move bishop g for just uh renewing the
threats against white's position so for
example h3 we're gonna take come in with
rook takes
and here for example
uh just to show white is doing okay with
the move queen to b2 when things are
going to simplify a little bit
and we'll get a drawn end game
i think that's the line at least
but if you get ambitious try and go
after the black king we simply go king
to f8 and again it's it's whites who is
getting checkmated here just to show you
what the computer thinks we are minus
two in this position you have to defend
your king right away if you start going
after ideas here king to e7 just defends
really everything uh in the black camp
just to play a few more moves we can go
queen h7 queen c5 is apparently strong
uh king h1 queen e3 and it's clear now
that's uh you know
white is under a lot of pressure
stockfish says minus three and a half
black is just totally totally crushing
um
and with that i think that's all the
time i have to talk about the debuff to
rush so there are of course a lot more
lines that you need to look at there's a
lot more to talk about here and if you
do want to learn a little bit more once
again i recommend that chestable course
i recommend just playing in your own
games seeing what happens looking at the
database going through some some of
these games that show up
uh but overall a very very very fun
opening a very active opening and an
incredibly incredibly useful opening so
once again i started my journey on the
duval terrace because of this very
annoying line knight to c3
which controls d5 and also threatens e4
and i cannot play my normal setups with
e6 because e4 is a very very strong move
here leaves leading to very difficult
lines for black that's where the duboff
terrace comes in with this move 2 to c5
so the last thing i want to talk about
is just how versatile this opening is
because me personally i find it to be
the most useful against the c49c3 setup
but just to show you if you fall in love
with the duke of terrace you can play
the duboff trash every game um for
example
knight to c3
uh c5 like you can do this here as well
um you do have to know some other lines
but if you do want to play the debuff to
rush that is your prerogative you are
going to get this position
a lot of the time
just one other way to get there through
the classical torage move order
so you can play it against d4 c4 you can
play it against c4 knight c3 you can
play it against uh really a lot of
different things a lot of different
setups for white one of the most
versatile openings and one of the most
fun openings that i've found
so any final questions for me before we
call it quits on the duboff terrace for
today
and i hand it over to gm josh fidel
any questions on the opening at all we
covered a lot today but hopefully you
feel confident in the main ideas again
it comes back to active play active
ideas
okay well with that thank you all so
much for joining me here tonight once
again josh fedele will be coming in in
just a moment to teach grand master's
choice the topic of his choosing
i had a great time looking at all these
lines prepping this lecture hopefully
you guys enjoy the dubai trash in your
own games
as always thank you so much for watching
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
[Music]
you